cats feel crushable though you're right
you know when you're petting them you're
like these are words they're not they're
not in there they're not in there yeah
you're like oh this is like you never
crushed your cat I gotta just crush them
[Music]
we're gonna talk about some more animals
today fellas whoa great more animal
abuse
yes damn really
and the other way around as well so cool
animal sex and elephant news
an elephante
stabs his Handler with his tusks and
then did that [ __ ] do one of
these with his nose honk with his Tusk
did it go through them
it went through them and then ripped
them in half a gangster don't they cut
the tusks off are you being serious I
swear it [ __ ] stabbed it and ripped
it in half after being given heavy
workload in extreme heat which half
which way you're testing dude vertical
hot dog style or hamburger style I have
this I think it's a hamburger I have
this like Vision in my mind like
sometime something's gonna happen where
all the animals are gonna send some
[ __ ]
signals to each other and they're like
in the middle of the night cats dogs
Birds everybody I don't know if you're
an elephant
[ __ ] up your master tonight that's what
we got lucky we're killing all of them
you gotta lock the door man
that's like Animal Farm like [ __ ] it
we're gonna kill all of them tonight is
that what happened they got sit down
there they can get fed up Kinda Yeah
they are gonna get yeah this is like uh
this is like an avatar the James Cameron
one with all the blue people right we're
at the very very end when they're all
losing and [ __ ] like that something all
the [ __ ] animals come through and
just rip everybody a new [ __ ] yes
that's that kind of [ __ ] but more
murderous like all these cannabin-ass
cats and dogs that's why when I go to
sleep I throw a rib eye on the front
lawn
no when they do come they get distracted
and then I sleep with my [ __ ] double
pistols you think any dogs like talking
to the dogs like let's go [ __ ] this dude
the other dog's like really they got
dogs if you go I'll go
go I'll go I can't picture a golden
retriever doing that yeah not a Goldie
yeah if you got a good owner the the
other dog could be a mischievous dog and
then your dog's like nah my owner's cool
yeah and golden retrievers they look
like down syndrome homeboys I know they
got like a nice smile on yeah they'll be
like that's your problem but they're
strong they can [ __ ] you up they want to
[ __ ] you that's true yeah they honestly
could I look at some of these dogs now
like if you want a cat too like oh cats
will [ __ ] you up your cats might in the
middle of night just murk you in the
middle of the night they're like I'm
just getting his threat let me just [ __ ]
you up how's your cat ever [ __ ] you up
I mean it's one of those things where
like as a cat owner they're [ __ ] you
up but you're like oh this is so cute
and then you're all bloody and [ __ ] like
that what do they do like
like that basically they're just you
know because they like scratched like if
you don't trim their nails consistently
to keep them like more dull they're
constantly growing out and scratching at
themselves you know in order to sharpen
it when they catch a juggler though if
they catch a juggling what are you gonna
do then man yeah what are you gonna do
that's what I'm saying they like no cats
feel crushable though you're right you
know when you're petting them you're
like these are words they're not they're
not in there they're not in there yeah
you're like oh this is like you never
crushed your cat I gotta just crush them
but I feel like they'll slip like a
[ __ ] octopus like you squeeze like
that and they'll slip out of your hand
you shouldn't have an elephant it's
definitely one of my rules I've had like
a dog small dog any animal I have have
to be an animal if they come down to it
yeah can take it you can take it you
have to I'm not gonna take it I'm not
getting no like big ass dog
or even a crazy pit but I'm like if it
went down it might take me he might take
me out I'm gonna have that dog so my
buddy has a friend who lives on an
elephant sanctuary in Cambodia and they
built a hotel right next to the
sanctuary so you could stay there and in
the morning do this food like showing me
videos Hey Joe like check this out he
goes out and he gets these baby [ __ ]
bananas and he's feeding a baby elephant
that's great dog and then little
[ __ ] raps his [ __ ] Tusk
around I mean the elephant like nose
around the trunk and then he grabs it
and then he [ __ ] eats it dude oh and
then they they [ __ ] do morning walks
they walk around that fool looks like
[ __ ] Mowgli and [ __ ] that's awesome
but I mean don't let it don't let it
fool you they don't get big as hell and
if you piss it off it's gonna rip
yourself elephant in Thailand has ripped
his 32 year old Handler in half after it
was given a heavy workload in extreme
dream healed I got mistreated them
though that's why that's the workload
anybody that has to work under the heat
is gonna get pissed that's where you
[ __ ] up what if it's like I need those
reports on my desk by Friday
authorities believe the animal named
pompan had grown frustrated at having to
transport rubber wood at a plantation in
fanya province in soaring temperatures
the 20 year old elephant stabbed their
Handler supachai Wang fade that's
probably whipping them go carry that
thing with his tusks before buying them
no there's something in there thinking
they smart they don't forget yo they're
elephants but those are good brains man
they're wise you ever seen Operation
Dumbo Drop that's one thing I missed I
miss riding on an elephant at the park
what part yeah back in the day that was
like still acceptable what park they
used to do that at the parks around here
in L.A yeah like at Griffith Park even
right they did a Griffith they used to
they just I remember as a kid
they [ __ ] some days you just be at
the park and there's just hell elephants
and then you pay a fee at the Griffin
Park I I was a child I forgot what it
probably was Griffith Park wow but then
yeah and then you just be sitting there
with a bunch of Mexican kids on an
elephant
chilling and all the kids always saw the
elephant poop and they're like
you know that stands out according to
reports local police The Village Chief
and rescue workers found Wong fade the
son of the former mayor of that sub
District ripped into lying in a pool of
Bloom oh his body was eventually
retrieved after livestock officers shot
the elephant with a sedative Dart
and just so you know death in Thailand
caused by elephants are rare but on the
rise with at least 20 people being
killed in 2020. the elephants are
uprised
they're sick of their [ __ ] he
does all these animals are just kind of
like humoring us until the time comes
middle of the night they get that signal
the bad signal [ __ ] up your honor
tonight [ __ ] [ __ ] up our Master it's
like Daenerys targan coming through it's
just like no everybody kill your Masters
and take off your chains yeah yes
exactly like the [ __ ] the rib eyes
ribeye steaks the worm and the whole
crew yeah gray worm and the unsullied
unsullied
unsolutely just like in the middle of
night you hear just some burp like fly
by eating and then like oh what the [ __ ]
was that that was the sound
I was just fantasizing about every
[ __ ] domesticated pet in the world
just on one giving you got a [ __ ]
parent going yeah [ __ ] biting the
owner goes down pet [ __ ] hamster
breakout and [ __ ] the [ __ ] pet
hamster killing his own [ __ ] snake
come out bite your toe and [ __ ] God
tarantulas
everything imagine all the you death by
chinchilla I mean you're sleeping
they're catching you when you're
sleeping plus I got a little jump on you
because it's like it's like Santa Claus
power and one night somehow gets all the
children in the world at one time did
you ever see the movie Maximum Overdrive
no is that what happened in the movie no
it sort of but there was like a sentient
truck that gave an electronic signal to
anything electronic to start killing
people so like vending machines would be
shooting soda people oh [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] down anything that could use
electricity was trying to kill him like
a refrigerator attacks you and [ __ ] hits
you in the face those movies we don't
see them no more huh yeah because they
can't well good movies yeah good movies
man like double drop dump Operation
Dumbo Drop what happens in that by the
way dude Ray Liotta's in Ray Liotta rest
in peace what is the operation they
gotta save the uh the elephant and
transport them to uh elephant Sanctuary
why are you looking at me like that
because dude Anthony you see we talk
about it all the time you're supposed to
back me up I'm backing you up dude hey
operation double drops about uh them
rescuing an elephant send them to
elephants you guys never seen operation
double drop
how do they stretch one drop into a
whole runtime film because dude people
are stopping him from dropping is it
what Charlie Sheen I think I think Danny
Glover's in it yeah I think he is too I
don't think I ever saw it but I remember
the posters in the trailer all right
here we go we got uh directed by Simon
Windsor with starring Danny Glover Ray
Liotta Dennis Leary Dougie Doug Corin
nameick whatever the [ __ ] he said Dougie
Doug I never seen any of those Walt
Disney Pictures blah blah blah it's on
Disney plus size it's by Walt Disney by
the man himself yeah is a 95 American
action comedy drama War film storyline
was conceived from screenplay written by
Gene no we need to tell War film too
it's a war film it was like military
it's like military a Dumbo Drop based on
a true story see United States Army
Major Jim Morris the film stars Donna
Glover and Ray Liotta as Green Berets
during the Vietnam war in 1968 who
attempts to transport an elephant
through jungle terrain to a local South
Vietnamese Village which in turn helps
American forces monitor Viet Cong
activity the film deals bro
damn I'm a welfare anti-viet Cong I
don't know if I want to watch this movie
anymore I did not support the one you
were recommending it the whole time no
because I remember for that if it had
nothing to do with the war yeah I guess
I don't even think it takes place
Vietnam because I think it's like
modified elephant I don't know man it's
a good movie bro they're trying to save
the elephant it is a a Disney movie so
like number two best elephant movie The
Protector with Tony Jones oh yeah that's
a good one the protective return dude
I'm not gonna buy a moped no more I'm
gonna buy a [ __ ] elephant he's been
scheming this whole time what a friend
of mine in New York rented an elephant
to propose to a his wife oh is he Indian
no he's Filipino that's interesting but
it wasn't a full grown outfit I think
it's a baby elephant because he was
riding it and he lives in a like a
high-rise building he's ready what right
that [ __ ] took the elephant he was
just on it and that's the answer he's a
wild artist and he just he he came with
a I think he had a turbo he was doing a
whole Aladdin thing he was like Grand
Sally but he was on the back of a
[ __ ] baby elephant in there like you
know some high-rise apartment they lived
in this was Apple the app yeah I imagine
bad guys with swords I still think it's
the craziest thing I was like why'd you
do this I just had an idea I was like
where the [ __ ] you get an elephant New
York he's like New Jersey
that's the easy answer transport him
through the subway elephants are
probably the top three coolest animals
[Music]
[Music]
foreign